this and that welcome to oh I thought
that was a silent welcome to our and I
was tasked to give some introductory
talk and trying to get people or on the
same page and I really want to thank all
the other speakers who have agreed to
come and as Alistair said I think the
top will be boring to the experts and I
apologize in advance and I really try to
hopefully make the elementary and
understandable and interrupt me anytime
you and so this is going to be actually
one of the several I think we plan on
three I'll give two and hung will give
the third on the classification program
and in fact she Chang will give some
other talks that very much related to
this and what I like to basically bring
everyone sort of to get a sense of what
this is all about is that you know we're
looking at problems but not necessarily
individual problems because we're
interested in individual problems but
the program is much more looking at the
class of problems and try to get a
dictionary of sort right it's sort of a
like a chemist you know here's the
element table you know we try to lay out
that in some sense this is perhaps the
ultimate goal for complexity theory you
try to classify everything you can we're
going to focus on a sum of product type
of computations for this game for
dichotomy theorems which try to classify
everything in a in a class and they tend
to be sort of sum of product
computations have been mostly successful
and in fact we'll have three frameworks
to discuss
and they are very much related here are
the three the first goes by sping
systems or graph homomorphisms or
weighted growth hormone office and
partition functions and we'll come to
that when we introduce slowly but
basically speaking say you have a set of
points and they have neighboring
interactions and the points can assume
let's say up or down valuations and
depending on if they're both up and up
or down down up and down and down up if
it's directed graph there only three
possibilities undirected graph is three
possibilities then you give some sort of
value of weight and then you multiply
these ways together as the total weight
and you sum of all the assignments in
statistical physics they some the
weights and then put on the exponent
which is really the same into the sum
and they have some parameters in front
there's at least almost a different view
but it's really essentially the same or
what's called growth hormone morphisms
which has a longer tradition in at least
as long traditionally combinatorics
we'll come to that CSP everybody
probably understands you have variables
that can take values in the Sun finite
domain and then you have a set of
constraint functions which can be used
to apply on various subsets of functions
actually subsequences functions because
they might be order dependent and then
you consider all the assignments to the
variable and you multiply the
evaluations of the function the function
if it's a 01 that's just a satisfaction
sort of if it's all satisfied on though
and then you sum over possible
assignments okay so
spring system can be viewed as a special
case of the CSP where you have a single
binary function eh and I will talk about
this framework called Holland which is a
generalization of CSP where say for
example perfect matching is one of those
problems where you assign values to the
edges if you pick the edge oh you don't
pick the edge and you add the vertex you
say I have to constrain which is exactly
one edge was picked that's a valid
configuration locally for perfect
matching and then you sum over all
possible assignments of the subset of
edges of 0 1 and you multiply with 0 and
that's the counting number of perfect
matches welcome to that actually
Friedman low bars and scribers showed
that you cannot express perfect matching
units being partition this is it
strict extension and then reverse its
it's obvious you can do one you can
simulate these guys by this these things
can all be talked on general domain and
if you have variables taking over red
and blue and agreeing a yellow and these
are called higher domain questions and
they tend to be more difficult to
classify and my talk here will be
focused on the boolean domain so you
have that's plenty to work on actually
the variables would take 01 okay the
values of the function can be arbitrary
complex numbers and I like to actually
in this talk focus on this newer
development the last 10-15 years about
holographic reductions as both a method
of proving hardness as well as
discovering the algorithms and then
ultimately has a way to classify
problems okay
oh okay so I'm actually writing a book
and it's currently in its draft form
it's on my website you can download then
some of the talks here will be based on
some chapters here for example today's I
think it's going to be on the chapter on
the match gates
okay so let's get going everyone knows
what the class number P or sharpy is
which is basically the counting version
of NP alright everybody knows what NP is
everybody knows what P is everybody with
no so Turing machine okay wait right
here egress here you know what Turing
machine is you you you account for the
number of steps that you're a machine
takes and think about non-deterministic
Turing machine as sort of a at every
point you might have a finite number of
choices as valid moves or you can say a
priori I'm given an X and a guess of why
of the polynomial a long and then
depending on the particular why I guess
I have a deterministic polynomial time
computation that's n ok and he says if
there is a why that makes it right makes
it exciting and sharpey is basically
defined as how many wise how many non
deterministic computational paths that
will make the acceptance right so you
think about like satisfiability is there
a satisfying assignment that's the NP
problem satisfiability numbers said is
how many satisfying assignments are
there virtually anything you can think
about an NP problem you can think of in
a counting version how many satisfying
assignments and you can even have waited
version these partition functions are
typical things of this sort in sum over
explanation and many possibilities each
one contributes some sort of way and you
want to stop them
as I said we would like to classify
broad classes of counting problems but
before we want to sort of assume that we
can classify we should at least acquaint
ourselves with something that are
actually computable I mean you should
know I guess that the whole philosophy
is that p is not equal to sharpie ok
this is a an assumption that everybody I
think mostly agree at least it's implied
by NP not equal to P if you think P
could a sharpie then this classification
program becomes not very interesting
because everything is EP but but
nevertheless this serums that are proved
here do not assume that in fact if you
want once had that the classification
that you can prove anything that is
considered the Sharpie hard in the
classification to prove in p then they
will solve your problem which is P
collision so let's just assume that p is
not equal to sharpie we would like to
classify and therefore we would like to
have at least some understanding of
things that are doable in polynomial
time okay so they are decision problems
versus the counting problem sometimes
the decisions are easy but counting's
are hard well more pertinent to us is
that actually there are some sharply
hard problems that are in general for
general for example perfect matching
county number perfect matching but it is
actually a solvable in polynomial time
over planar graphs this is a very
non-trivial class of problems that you
would like to get at your understanding
exactly okay we're trying to get so this
talk is going to be primarily an
introduction to the algorithm called the
custodians algorithm which computes the
number of perfect matchings or the way
to the sum of perfect matchings over
planar graphs in polynomial time and
then using that as a has an engine has a
basic tool to
trying to come up with some other
algorithms and then one of the goal of
the classification program here
eventually will be and I think maybe how
much today in the third lecture is to
prove that in a very strong sense these
are the universal method that anything
that are generally hard over general
graphs to count Carter meaning that it's
sharpie hard but becomes polynomial-time
solvable the planar graphs is doable in
this way ok we have theorems that the
state to the effect that over the broad
class of CSP problems this is universal
but for the Holland problems turns out
that it isn't and so there are some very
surprising additional things that are
sharpie Harding general graphs but not
in polynomial time of a planar graphs
but are not doable by this
transformational universal method if you
think about it the claim of the
universality of someone method of this
in the class level is rather amazing
because I don't think there is any such
thing say decision problems if somebody
tells you this problem can be solved by
dynamic programming if you see it you
know it but what does it mean by cannot
be solved by time and there's no real
formulation in that sense that lacking
is such a formal definition that much
less of any proof of this sort ok so as
I said this is known as the FK T
algorithm named after Fisher temporarily
independently and castalian
independently they actually did
independently on the grid first and then
castilian did on the planar graph so
sometimes just call the castalian so
formally mathematically the planar
version is due to customs so proof
anyway
let the same algorithm so f Katie
sometimes go okay in order to introduce
that I would first have to go too far
phien okay and I assume that at least
half of you probably know what fashion
is but let me let me let me let me use
Don Knuth claim that it's more important
than determinants so at least you have
every reason to want to know this is a
half sentence the fact that the fluffy
ins are more fundamental determinants is
something to the effect that he said
that determinants are basically
bipartite special cases of part favia
which is really but I'm not sure in the
community of algebra community people
would believe the determinants are
anything second to anything else right
this is like but anyway so you will see
they are very much related anyway so
what is a [ __ ] you start with an a
skew symmetric so anti symmetric matrix
so let let's think we all talk about
over complex numbers so there's no
characteristic to business to monkey and
then you look at this matrix and then
there's a matrix function okay it's a
value if the excise are complex numbers
then the fafi end of this matrix is is
this polynomial is this fat so here's
that formal definition you're given an
n-by-n skew symmetric matrix of even
order the old orders are defined to be 0
and the fashion is very much like the
determine DC there's a sighing over
permutations and then these are the
products of different roles in different
columns but formally you're summing over
permutations that are expressed as this
way 12 I 1 to 2 I 2 and so on okay for
each permutation you insist you have
this additional constraint some
definitions don't require that and there
is a multiplier and then you have to
move out but we will come to that in a
minute let's stick with one definition
so you stick with this particular
permutation exist that I 1 is less than
I 2 I 3 is a lesson
I for I sub 2 K minus 1 is a less than I
sub 2 K and then I one is a less than I
three and then less than that okay so so
first test first quiz for the mornings
at the you to see that you're awake that
I 1 is 1 by this constraint yes okay yes
so what is this is really saying is that
let's pick the smallest I 11 here and
let's pick its mate I to okay and then
take the i1 i2 out the remaining I 3
must be the smallest remaining and you
take that if I to is not to then I three
is too if I three I to is not to then I
three is too and if I to is to then I
three is three ok so is to pick the
smallest and you say what's the the mate
for I three in other words you're
looking at the partitions of this n into
pairs of disjoint tuples and you
canonically name such a partition that's
what it is one must belong to one of the
pair and that's the i one and it's made
is called I to ok and then you look at
the smallest lexicographic the smallest
pair that's i3 i-4 and so on so forth so
if you think about the partitioning of n
into pairs of disjoint pairs then there
is obvious association with the perfect
matchings right so you have n points
even and you somehow try to pair up in a
disjoint way now of course the pair's if
you think about these pairs of points of
i 1 i 2 1 2 up to and as not necessarily
as points but they are not necessary
with edges then this particular
partition will correspond to a perfect
matching if and only if every one of
those particular pairs is an edge so so
the sum is overall potential perfect
matchings and the value if you think of
this as sort of adjacency matrices then
this will be give you a nonzero term if
and only if it's a perfect matching but
with a sign
ok so the clear so that's that's what
the definition of fashion is and the
sign of a permutation because the
ordinary Thane group theory this is an
odd permutation or even permutation the
definition is if you have written down
as a product of transpositions it's an
even number of transposition so hard and
that parody is invariant that's all
right as I said there's a one-to-one
correspondence between the foreign terms
and these partitions and of course every
such partition for every permutation
whether or not satisfying the
stipulation of this this ordering
business correspond to such a partition
right you just pick the first to the
second but then for every partition
there is a unique way to write down this
permutation now pick such a permutation
that not necessarily satisfy this
stipulation you can still define such a
term and because that this matrix is a
skew symmetric that if you switch the i1
i2 o ik ik plus 1 it changes the sign
exactly by one for the permutation and
this is a skew symmetric also
contributes a negative sign so therefore
in fact you can write down this thing
for the matrix and will be the same
regardless of what the permutation
satisfies the stipulation or not as long
as it belongs to the same partition so
every partition correspond to oh I don't
know some and K factorial and then 2 to
the K many different ways the right
exactly one of them is a canonical and
every one of those terms corresponds the
same term so another way of writing the
fashion more like the determinant is too
subtle all permutations and they divide
out by this
k vector so this well it's it's it's
interesting that I could compute this
thing regardless if the PI satisfied of
stipulation now there is a silver
essentially equivalent to way of looking
at these signs that you can define
what's called a crossover so if you have
four indices if you list the smaller one
before the bigger one and then you say
the red pair and the blue pair had a
crossover if they have this sort of a
condition ok so this or this and of
course there's the only other two
configurations when they are ordered
pair is this way or that way and there
they are not crossed over and this is
crustal
it would be the case if you write down
these four points on a semi-circular
point a curve you have and then you have
the red here and the blue there and this
is a crossover and if you order it in
such a way that they don't cross over
geometric rate that they don't cross
over it's also nice geometric definition
okay so now there's a claim now that the
sign is the minus to the number of
crossovers in the permutation so I'm
writing down the permutation with the
stipulation and then I claim that in
fact the sign can be computed
combinatorially as as how many
crossovers are there and count is even a
hard and the way to see that is
basically you put your lower list of
numbers in this permutation as 1 2 3 2 K
and then you have I 1 I 2 I 3 I to K
this is already in the stipulation so
this is actually one and this is the you
know the pair that that's associated
with the Iowa in the partition and and
then this is the smallest remaining and
so on so forth the stipulation and then
you just imagine that how many
transpositions are you going to perform
to move it back to this sorted order
okay and the parody of that is exactly
the sign of course this is we're doing
inverse of this transposition this
permutation so the sign of that is is
the number of is the parity of the
number of the trans positions that will
go and so you think about
we're two is and you try to move at the
back or so imagine that the pairs that
are both inside they are patched then
they don't contribute even and otherwise
those crossovers will be moved by
exactly one so when you move this thing
over just to put two in right place then
it's exactly the number of its the
parody of the number of crossovers of
the pair i won I to form by any other
pairs and now you do induction after
that ok so so this is just the if you
want to move the two in the right place
then this is exactly crossovers you form
with the first pair with the rest
now the Falcon can be computed in
polynomial time there is a way to do it
like the Gaussian elimination and in
fact there is this well-known identity
which says the determinant is equal to
the square of the [ __ ] the fact that
these things can be computed in Poland
in the time is important help so far the
we are thinking about a graph with edges
of complex weights or just but you can
think about symbolically the edges
having a polynomial indeterminant x ok
so you can have for each edge assign an
indeterminant x whenever there is an
edge but in order to be anti symmetric
you have to assign for the edge in one
way and the other with a negative sign
so this is just sort of symbolically
write down the adjacency matrix as we
have
um let the mg denote the set of perfect
matchings and we already commented that
for a particular permutation this
partition is the perfect matching if and
only if all the pairs are edges
so I'm going to define the weight of a
perfect matching as simply you multiply
the indeterminant on the edges sometimes
it's a little confusing if you think
bodies are complex numbers and these can
be already negatives and then the
weights could be negative and so on but
for now this is why I choose to think
about them as indeterminant so don't
worry about the negative part of the
weights themselves we'll have plenty of
negatives to worry about in a minute
because they have negative x i's have a
place later on but right now we're just
thinking so the straightforward a
monomial which is the weight of the turf
information now let's think about an
orientation of the graph which is
basically to assign one and only one
direction forever eh okay so you take
every edge 79 you can orient from seven
to nine or you can orient from nine to
seven that's an orientation for every
edge you assign that that's called an
oriented graph and for all n to the
graph let's modify this matrix in the
following way namely if you are ordering
from orienting from u to V then you just
put this X appear there otherwise you if
you offer the direction of reversely if
you orient it from V to you then you put
a negative thing in this entry of BU
okay another way of thinking about this
is to say that our modified a to be in
the following way this a can be viewed
as where is it that I'm sort of by
default orienting from the lower to the
higher and if i were to orient in such a
way that for a particular edge the
orientation was the reverse then i put a
negative sign there but if i want to put
a negative sign after put an egg design
the other side which may already have a
negative okay
flip so that's the that's the definition
of this adjacency anti-symmetric
adjacency matrix for an oriented graph
this what I'm saying that you can just
think about this is modifying a in this
way and now you can think about the
fashion of this matrix B which is
designed for the modified or the
oriented graph [ __ ] for any anti
symmetric matrix is well defined so this
is the fashion and you can think about
this fashion and think about an
arbitrary term and I mentioned that this
quantity you can write down the pie
whether or not it satisfied the
stipulation or not doesn't matter as
long as the matrix B is an anti
symmetric then you can write down the
pie for any permutation that
representing the partition
okay so now comes the definition to call
the sign of this perfect matching you've
given a perfect match in in oriented
graph and you define this sign as this
ratio remember this is just sort of do
irregardless of the orientation they
just put the weights there and this is
the term that I just defined which is
course always going to be a plus minus
sign you can say that the perhaps all of
this business is about the plus minus
sign but that's kind of making it too
little because this is aware in fact we
think is not polynomial time computable
versus what is polynomial computable
separates okay so determinants Fuffy ins
counting perfect merchants planar graphs
becomes polynomial time computable
precisely because the care for signing
of the sign and if you don't have the
sign of the permanent and these are
typical sharpie hard problems
okay so we could this one this is just a
product this is the weight of the
perfect matching so we had this oh it's
just product without worrying about
okay we can compute this with any
permutation they're satisfied not that
the canonical one because the invariants
do we noted about this term that's
coming sometimes convenient so for
example we can always write down the
permutation as simply the edges go from
this to that I always go from here today
this is not in general going to be the
canonical representation for the
permutation but i can write this way and
computer its sign and that will be
exactly this okay so now let's consider
there are two perfect matchings okay
suppose you have two perfect matches
what do you do whenever you have two
perfect matches there's only one thing
you should do whenever you have to put
this is of course for the graduate
students in if you have two perfect
matchings the only thing you do the
first thing to do is to do an XOR right
when do an XOR then the set of edges of
the union of the two perfect matchings
gets partition into alternating cycles
as well as the common edges that would
be you can think of the cycles of this
listen so you take one edge of em but
Nottingham Prime let's say and that
vertex on the other side is perfectly
matched by M prime or something unique
with okay there must not be n because m
is already matched em edge here and then
you have this vertex must be matched by
M prime so there's a n prime age and and
this must not be the perfect matching
edge the blue the perfect matching in
action this must not be this therefore
must be this and therefore now this
vertex must then be matched by M prime
so there's another one this is M Prime
and this is him and so of course we're
talking about fine i graph so eventually
would have to come back and it has to
come back to this that's the only place
so whenever you're given two perfect
matchings the first operation you should
think like when you're sleepy the first
thing you do is write the X or that
gives you a bunch of alternating cycles
as well as common edges what you see oh
so that's what you do you do the axle ah
then you have a bunch of even then
cycles this is even rice it's a blue
green blue
blue red glow red okay so now I'll give
a very technical definition at this
point and after the lecture you can
forget about is another very fundamental
definition unlike some of the others
okay so here's a technical definition
says that for an oriented graph take a
psycho even lens and we say it's evenly
oriented if there is an even number of
edges oriented in one direction pretty
natural definition okay it doesn't
matter which direction of course right
because it's even so if they've even
this way and then you're doing that even
that way okay so that's called evenly
oriented otherwise it's called oddly all
right oddly oriented even cycle
as the now comes a lemma I say that the
sign of perfect matching em and assign
the perfect matching Hamming an oriented
graph G is going to be the minus 1 to
the number k where k is the number of
evenly oriented cycles even cycles in
this season so that's that's a nifty
year claim you take the red and blue
perfect matching you do the XOR you get
a bunch of even cycles and then you
count because these edges are oriented
and you count how many evenly oriented
cycles are there and this identity hold
it is a proof sketch if it holds for one
orientation than in the holes for all
orientations so this is just a little
local change if you orient one edge on
the psycho a little differently then
both will change the sign but this
doesn't get changed
um sorry if you change one edge than one
change the other doesn't change and this
does it change make sure that you didn't
let me pass him that okay and then the
claims that you can choose an
orientation and you can have it so that
it's easy for us to discuss so for every
cycle which is oriented this way okay so
for every cycle which is orienting a
cyclic way it doesn't matter which
orientation it's every orientation would
if one orientation works then all
orientation work so you can choose the
orientation you like so now we are
getting away with the orientation on
given and doing a way that's convenient
for us for the particular to perfect
matchings m and M Prime and now we can
we label the vertices again we claim
that if you after the relabeling if this
worked then originally the work so it's
again this is sort of I guess the proof
buying variants or something I know that
there's a it has to be a name for this
sort of proof technique right you try to
push push push push into a very
standardized the canonical way and then
you say ah now it's obvious so you're
going to real able vertices and again if
you think about it carefully you're
going to change both sides basically so
imagine you have a permutation like this
they are gonna do it another relabeling
and then you choose the M so that this
is the M and then you do this and you
compose these two and you just get one
to Kate this so you choose the
permutation you write it this way
because generally permutation you write
down one two three but you can write any
any what do you like right so you choose
the permutation this way and then if the
original M is written this way where the
oriented edge is always go from I 12 hi
to hai sri akal then after this will be
labeling it's also going from j12 j2 and
j-3 to j 4 so therefore the sign as I
told you the sign can be computed in any
particular way of writing a permutation
representing it it will be the sign of
this composition of this to permutations
okay now what about this well you now
have an M Prime and then for the M prime
you actually have a different way of
writing the permutations right but now
you use the same relabeling permutation
riding it according to how the n prime
is reshuffle the thing you represent it
this way then the product again will be
the sign of this permutation for the
other other term so the change of this
and a change of that are both by
multiplying by the parody of the
permutation of this and of course that's
a plus minus one so the product becomes
one so the change is no change okay so
if you re labeling it doesn't change
this changes this and change this by the
parody of this both therefore it doesn't
change
you and so now we can real able and will
we label in a very convenient way for
example in the cycle we just had cycle
even cycle you just hold it this way
starting with one that's in one two
three and in this way it is clear that
this is identity because the
permutations just want to sew and that's
how the accommodation would be and this
is a cyclic shift so 1 2 3 becomes 2 3 4
that's how the permutation would be this
permutation that this is 1 23 of 23 food
right so this is an edge this is an edge
is the reason age 45 and age so that's
going to be the parity of this but this
is the even cycle so it's even cycle
it's it's odd as a funny treatment even
psychos odd parity wise
and then you have bunch of cycles and
you're multiplying that's exactly what
this quantity is because every cycle now
it's even they oriented I'm orienting
this way everything is evenly oriented
so the number of cycles and that's
exactly number of fact so you know it's
all worked out right it should be see
here's another metal thing that we seem
to come to appreciate in this
classification program is that in order
to be polynomial time computable
something very beautiful has to just
work out okay so something you know
extremely pretty that it's just
perfectly fits is a good sign that
there's something polynomial time
algorithm lurking around so this is an
example okay so after this you real able
consecutive dancers exactly had to tell
and you will get exactly right okay
finally you get to define the other
side's identity this sign is exactly
number of even cycles which is the
number of evenly oriented cycles
okay so now I come to this definition
called the fashion orientation which is
at the heart of the custodians FK
okay so a faulty and orientation I'm
talking about a planar graph now a
connected planar graph an orientation of
the planar play planar graph is called
[ __ ] orientation if along the boundary
of every non outer face the outer face
doesn't count every internal know how to
face there is an odd number of clockwise
oriented ageism so that's the definition
of
so now we'll prove this lemma this is
that whenever I gave you a Fafi an
orientation if you now look at every
cycle cycle could pound a face or could
bounce several phases the internally
they are other faces again just a cycle
they look around the cycle the number of
clockwise oriented edges is of the
opposite parity of the number of
vertices inside
you look at a planar graph and then you
look at the particular cycle and here
are edges inside now you look at number
vertices an account and you say the
number of clockwise oriented edges of
this edges I'm going this way some going
that way you count the number of
oriented cycles in a clockwise sense it
has exactly the opposite parity of the
number of vertices inside the clear the
claim so when I say inside I don't
include a number of vertices on the
cycle
so let's V and E be the number of
vertices and edges contained inside this
cycle and let L be the number of edges
on the cycle which is also the number of
vertices on the cycle ok as I said the
vertices inside is strictly inside not
on the cycle suppose they are f faces
one two three four five six seven eight
how many faces are they bounded by the
inside of this cycle and let see I be
the number of clockwise oriented edges
on the boundary on each of the cycles
now every internal edge like this
contributes once in the clockwise count
of one phase but the other counts 0 it
counts exactly one contributes exactly
12 the count of clockwise oriented edges
for the internal ages if you sum over
every face but the external edges will
contribute one only once because it's on
the outside that's only one facing side
so everyone contributes really one now
take the number of faces things i said
it's odd every face has an odd number of
oriented cycle it's all so this is zero
there's a one more to every one of them
so f is equal to the congruent is
congruent to the sum of the count of the
number of orient clockwise oriented
edges to h-mart too ok this is just
saying f is a congruent to sum of one
month to every CI is 1 month
now of course there's the Euler's
formula is where the plan ality comes
right the number of vertices including
the points on the cycle is V Plus L the
number of edges is e + l the number
faces is f plus 1 because there's this
one external phase outside of this cycle
forget about these edges altogether just
think about this and the external place
and that quantity has to be two and
doing some arithmetic you get this
quantity so this is the part that we had
okay and we had this some to be
congruent to F
and this thing says that every edge
inside n as well as on the surface
clockwise edges contributes exactly 12
this this con this cat this is the
number of edges inside it contributes
exactly one whenever you some for all
the internal faces the clockwise edges
once in the one face for which it's
clockwise and the other it doesn't
contribute and the e does the c is the
number of clockwise edges on the outer
surface outer cycle that contributes
also one okay so you get this quantity
this equal to that and by the Euler get
this and you get this quantity so it
just falls out okay so this says the
number but it is strictly ink side
versus the number of clockwise oriented
edges on the cycle that you picked is of
the opposite parity
oh and so now the the key point is to
say that if you have a [ __ ]
orientation then these two signs for any
two perfect matchings will have the same
son okay so this is all the this this
this game is all about about that you
eventually get to this point that's the
whole thing so so you're given to
perfect matchings because it's a perfect
matching in a planar graph the vertices
inside cannot match outside because this
is Anna psycho that's made of the
alternating you take two perfect
matching do the XOR remember okay so
when did it XOR then the vertices inside
cannot be matched outside so the number
of vertices inks I must be even so the
number of clockwise oriented edges must
be hard so therefore it's not an even
it's not an even oriented cycle that
definition even number of Orion thanks
so therefore the science is going to be
what the others okay
so with the same sign we are now ready
to link this directly with perfect
matchings as we have been talking about
the fashion always has this width up to
a sign connection with perfect matchings
and now we are going to say that they
are really the same if you have the
[ __ ] orientation really the same up
to a global factor of positive possibly
minus one but they are all the same sign
Athena so let's define a perfect
matching polynomial this is like what
the permanent would have said and some
of all things of the product without any
additional artificial sign on the
permutation and if you assign these in
determines B 1 then this will count the
number of perfect matchings and now here
is the theorem of castellón that says
that are for any connected planar graph
you can assign a [ __ ] orientation and
once you can come to that later this
faulty orientation can be computed in
polynomial time in fact faster and using
that you can compute the this number of
perfect matches but I thought you
basically ok
now intuitively if you have a planar
graph and you want to make sure that on
every face you havin a the right
orientation you have enough odd number
of clockwise or until edges then just
sort of grow right you just you know
sign it okay odd and then look at here
this is already assigned so you do
something on these three edges so that
it's right and here and here you can
keep grow grow grow grow grow and then
it seemed to be fine right okay this is
not quite right because sometimes when
you just did this growing at some point
you may come to a little contradiction
there's no no guarantee of consistency
if you just not able to do that but this
idea is basically right so what you do
is you take the connector planar graph
you can compute its minor embedding of
cropped origin and if it's a tree than
any orientation works because there's no
psycho there's no requirement it's not a
psycho then there must be an edge that's
on a cycle if not a tree there must be
an edge on a cycle and you just traverse
the external hedges if an edge is not on
a cycle it must be a scutage and you can
break them and then inductively over
here and over there there must be an
edge that's our cycle and then you paste
back that's an edge on a cycle so you
can always easily find an edge that is
on a face on on the face of the
embedding and internal face
okay and now you take this edge away and
that you know either disconnects it
which then it's easy or it just breaks
one particular face like this edge is
being broken out and then you
inductively do what you need to do for
the orientation so that every face has
on a [ __ ] orientation and then you
append this edge is orientation one way
or the other to make this face right
remember the fovea orientation does not
require anything on the outer face okay
so so you don't need to worry about what
the outer face will have this gives you
the [ __ ] orientation is that clear
it's very simple right okay so you can
get a [ __ ] orientation and once you
have the [ __ ] orientation
you write down the skew symmetric matrix
for the orientation I gave you for the
[ __ ] orientation for the graph and
then the fashion will either be the
perfect matching or the negative of the
perfect matching as a polynomial now
because every term in the fashion for
each perfect matching has exactly the
same sign they are both positive or
negative relative to the weight of the
perfect mention yeah so that was now
there is this sort of issue if you write
down this whole thing and then you still
want to compute the perfect matching
which one is it is a plus or minus you
computer fashion egg well one quick and
easy way is to say well I just set all
the way to be one if your original
weight may not be all one I don't care
sigh or the one and compute a fluffy end
for the particular fashion orientation I
just made and i get a value and this
value is either positive or negative or
it could be 00 would be there is no
perfect matching right ok and it seems
it's or one the perfect matching part
must be the number perfect match might
be non-negative so you know which one is
it and then you go back to the original
weight and recompute that's a long way I
think there are other ways
this is not the same as the sighing
issue when you have the far phien square
you could a determinant you compute a
determinant then you still have the
issue of its the Falcon being plus or
minus okay but actually you could
compress the two things here together by
computing the determinant and then you
know that plus or minus sign is if it
has a bunch of connected components then
just compute component wise let's be
perfectly so that gives you the
polynomial time algorithm okay five
minutes to
I'm trying to be a slow going and hope
hope for you so we can follow everything
I really want to make it an elementary
here okay now with the [ __ ]
orientation and custodians algorithm in
hand that we can define what's called
the match gates so what is the match
gate well it's basically a undirected
weighted planar graph with some of
vertices outside as designated as
external 830 seesaw edges dangling edges
coming so you have something like here
here here the three bill disease that or
external okay and the match gates are to
be considered as whether this edge and
this edge and this edge are being
externally matched or not and once you
externally match this and not that and
not that then you would match this by
removing this together with incident
edges and you say what's the perfect
matching value inside and that will
become one entry of the match gates so
given a match gates like for example
three external nodes it will define a
vector or a tensor of thinking terms
entries there will be eight values and
they correspond to particular patterns
of external vertices being externally
matched or not given that particular
matching consideration what's the
internal perfect matching value so
that's the match gate so formally
speaking you take a pattern of zero ones
and you remove the vertices that have a
one in the graph you compute this
perfect matching value ok so that's that
gives you a bunch of values and that
assembles into a potential for a vector
as being perfect matchings of course it
is the case that only half of the
entries can be nonzero at most because
by parody what remains has to be even in
order to have a nonzero perfect matching
value so if G has an odd number vertices
that you must
move all number vertices externally to
make it possible to have a perfect
matching inside if you remove even
number vertices what remains will still
be odd and there will be 0 the value
will be 0 so the perfect matching can be
viewed as a Holland problem and you can
assign the exact one function at every
vertex and pick an edge to be in or out
ok and now here's the definition of it's
called Holland son you're given a set of
constraint functions for example exact
one function or at most one function if
there's at most one function that will
be not necessarily perfect matchings and
sum over all possible edge assignments
of this product which in the 0 1 case
will be either yes or no in general will
be some sort of weight and this quantity
will is in the perfect matching case
book exact one function here will count
number of perfect matches
let's look at a maybe i'll be i'll stop
here i'll pick up the next okay so it's
not a good idea to rush yeah right any
questions
now you're understood yeah what I am
talking about here as well as what comes
next time we'll all pretty much in the
book that I'm writing that you can take
a look and are plenty of papers on the
website
I know if that's would you repeat the
question can't hear them FK t seems to
have a topological flavor so I mean is
there any extension to the solution
X genus you can do it but
so the EPI an orientation is supposed to
be like a spin structure you think about
it that way then you need some national
spin structure for our general complex
if anybody ever consider this question I
need it needs to look like a manifold
grade I think so there are some work
ming-chi and law do and they have done
some extensions on higher genus and
certain violations of plan ality what
you can do I think generally say for
Gina's for example you can have a
polynomial time algorithm with G on the
exponent into the hood or g polynomial
time algorithm but if you want to use
the so i didn't quite get to the use of
the match guedes if you want to use
match gates in general as non planar
then to substitute into a general CSP
problem for example then there is no
guarantee that you can maintain the
genus to be bounded because they're
going to replicate in unbounded fashion
now once the genus is unbounded them
it's shoppy horrid dichotomy theorem
says you can't unless you think sharpie
you could please
thanks Judy and go to break